Many of you
still look back on your failures.
And you are letting it define who you are.
How amazing is that he did not
let his failures define him.
But God chose to use him and God
has a purpose for you as well.
We do not have stress - worry -
anxiety - because our trust is in God.
Hey guys,
Why are some men so resilient?
It looks like everything they try to do
- to accomplish - is just successful.
Why is that?
What makes them different from other men?
In my new book, Bold Pursuit, I said the
difference between success and failure
is often a matter of perspective and perseverance.
And I'm going to talk about this a little
bit more throughout the video.
And when we turn to the Bible:
[2 Chronicles 15:7]
The reason why so many men give up
easily is because they believe a lie.
They believe that every setback is a failure.
And they assume that the problem is them.
That they are a failure.
The truth is that every setback
is a learning experience.
It can make you wiser if you let it.
You see, setbacks are there.
They're going to happen
whether you like it or not.
It's just part of life.
The question is, what do you
do with it - and about it?
C.S. Lewis said:
You see, you need to change the way that
you think about trials and tribulations.
And failures.
Especially if you're a Christian.
That they are there to test you, that you need
to learn from it, knowing, alright, this is what
happened when I did this, so I'm gonna change the
way I do this if this is going to happen again.
So it improves you as a man.
In fact, the more you fail, the more you grow.
Why?
Because if you learn from it - it changes
the way you think and do certain things.
And that is how you improve.
Albert Einstein said:
You see, failure teaches us
perseverance, to keep on trying.
Going, going at it.
Learning from our failures
until finally we made it.
We have achieved success.
This wisdom is nothing new.
Solomon wrote about it thousands of years ago.
[Proverbs 24:16]
You see, that is how true reborn Christians
are different from the rest of the world.
Because we will always have the right
perspective and perseverance living in
righteousness, according to God's will.
Because we live through the Spirit in
the middle of failure.
And you see, James said:
[James 1:2-4]
This means we will never give
up, and we can easily handle
failures if we handle it through the
power of the Spirit that is in us.
Never having stress, or anxiety about
it, but if you do it through the flesh,
you will always worry.
Have stress.
Because you do not fully trust God.
And Paul also says:
[Romans 5:3-5]
And this is how we, as men in Christ, reborn
Christians, can also show the world that we are
different in a way that we handle difficult times.
Our trials and tribulations.
Showing that we do not have stress - worry
- anxiety - because our trust is in God.
We don't have self-confidence,
we have God confidence.
We show them how we deal with failures,
with this immense inner strength that
we know does not come from ourselves but it
comes from God, who created heaven and earth.
But if you act in the flesh, just in your soul
level with your own emotions, your own intellect,
your own will, it'll do the opposite.
Because then you look just
like the rest of the world.
And if you act in the flesh, you will fail.
And that kind of failure is not good.
In my new book I gave this example:
[Matthew 26:69-75]
You see, instead of telling the truth
and facing the consequences, Peter lied.
He denied even knowing Jesus.
He didn't just do it once - he did
it three times - he had three opportunities to do
the right thing and he failed all three of them.
After his third denial, Peter felt intense guilt
and shame and he repented for what he had done.
He learned from his mistake.
Then he did something else.
He showed up.
He didn't hide.
He didn't let his embarrassment get to him.
He didn't worry what other people said about
him behind his back or in front of him.
When the disciples got it again, Peter showed up.
When he heard that Jesus's tomb was empty,
he showed up there too.
As fast as he could.
Peter persevered.
He refused to let his failure define him.
You see, God chose Peter to lead the church.
How amazing is that.
He did not let his failures define him.
Many of you still look back on your failures
and you are letting it define who you are.
Peter overcame it and led the church - a
normal fisherman - but God chose to use
him and God has a purpose for you as well.
If God calls you to do something,
He knows you can do it.
And He will equip you with what you need
to accomplish His will for your life.
You see, that's the difference between men
who are spiritually mature - who walk with
God - because they act in the will of God.
And that is why God's blessing is on them,
and it seems like they are just
successful in everything that they do.
They don't have self-confidence,
they have God confidence,
And that is why they never
give up no matter what they do.
They know that God has their back
and they walk within His will.
God says, do this and they do it.
They know that God will keep His word.
[Galatians 6:9]
Now most of you who worked really hard for
what you have, walking within the will of God,
going through very tough times - you know most
of all that success tastes a lot sweeter when
you went through hardships.
And when you persevered,
until the end, through failure.
If you put God first in everything that
you do, then you know the good and the bad -
it will work together for good towards you.
[Romans 8:28]
Now, if some of you are in this failure state,
make sure that what you're trying to attempt
is the will of God for you.
Because if it is, it will
be successful, even if it's hard at times.
You still know that you will continue and endure.
So if that's where you are - you're
fighting through the Spirit - you're
not giving up. You're enduring.
You're battling this day-in/day-out.
Then you always need to remember
this while you are fighting.
Through the power of the
Spirit, remember this, always:
[Romans 12:12]
Now, if you want to grow faster, understanding
what it means to have God confidence and not just
self-confidence, if you want to grow spiritually
stronger as a man, then please get my new book.
It's called Bold Pursuit, a 90-day
devotional for men seeking the heart of God.
You can get the link to the book
in the video description below.
And also on our website.
Before you go, always remember this.
Life is short, so don't waste yours.
Bye guys.